so my question uh just sort of focuses
on two sort of different things we've
been talking about
uh one which is focusing on the
decisions people make and how that
influences how successful they are
and two you made a comment saying um in
america we don't afford you you know
equality of wealth or things like that
we give you equality of
access well equal access to rights not
not equal access
okay there is a difference what i mean
by equal access to rights obviously
is i mean that no one's going to get in
your way that the rights that you hold
are the same as the rights that i hold
but when i say
and if somebody blocks them then that's
blocking your access but
what i don't mean is that a person who
has a million dollars in the bank is
equally situated with a person with five
dollars in the bank because obviously
that's stupid
uh yes and i i would agree that that's
stupid um
good we're an agreement on stupidity all
right yeah um something we can't agree
on
um so
um i i do want to sort of extend that
into
i i do personally believe that the
number one factor in
a lot of these sort of things are the
decisions you make um
but a lot of what affects your decisions
is sort of where you start out and
sometimes that's like a long sort of
cultural argument and things like that
but other times
it's something more basic like well if
you weren't born into as wealthy a
family it's harder to
go to a nicer college and you're
pressured to take another job so you
don't finish
high school or you have to take care of
you know it's a single parent household
which you didn't decide your parents
made poor decision
yes but then you have to take care of
your little siblings or things like that
so
then it becomes harder for you to
maintain your job and you lose that so i
think
um there's a lot of sort of things that
100 this is correct yeah
three sort of key tickets you've talked
about
that are heavily influenced by factors
entirely out of a person well i mean
not having based on a wedlock is
definitely not influenced by factors
beyond your control i mean unless you
have uncontrollable genitalia
so that's it so you know so the fact is
that just because you had a single mom
doesn't mean that you have to follow in
the pattern bottom line is
that when you have cycles of poverty
somebody's gonna have to break that at
some point and that's gonna take an act
of will
when it comes to graduating from high
school the number of people who are
dropping out of high school because they
need to
you know support their family is
incredibly low in the united states but
if that's the case
then you know i i'll give you an example
there's a there's a listener of mine
who's a
young woman thinks she's probably 18
years old who emailed me the other day
and she said
you have your three rules right don't
have babies before marriage and
and get finished high school and then
get a job and she said
i love your show i agree with everything
you say i also broke one of those rules
so i have a baby i had a baby when i was
15 years old and what should i
do about that and i said well i replied
to her and i said what's your social
structure like why did you have a
new parents nearby who can help out with
your kid do you have a church that you
belong to people who you can rely on
and so i'm not really a member of a
church i don't have like a huge social
structure i have my mom my mom's also a
single mom
because there are these pathologies
where where there are generations of
single mothers
uh and uh and so what should i do and
she said well i went ahead and i got my
ged
and now i'm trying to go to community
college but i don't have money for child
care
i don't have money for child care my mom
works so what should i do and i said
well why don't you put together a
gofundme
and get it to me and i'll push it out
there and so she sent me a gofundme i
put 100 bucks in the kitty and an hour
and a half later she had six thousand
dollars
the reason that i did that and the
reason i tell the story is not because
i'm such a wonderful dude although i am
the reason that uh the the reason that i
tell this story
is because there is a world of willing
people who are willing to give and help
you escape these things if you want to
make the effort
there's whole groups of people out there
there's whole organizations dedicated to
helping you escape
making bad decisions dedicated to
helping you get out of poverty and if
people need to find these things
then please email me email your church
email your synagogue
there are entire religions dedicated to
this and this idea that these are
these inescapable chains of poverty the
no decision you make can help you escape
these things
you know if that's true then we're not
doing good enough job on a private level
but i don't think it's true i think the
american people are the most generous
people on the face of the earth
statistically speaking that is eminently
true
uh republicans by the way do give much
more money to charity than democrats
mainly because they're religious
um and uh
and so our goal as individuals not as a
society because i don't like to talk
about our goals as a quote unquote
society our goal is individual should be
to help people make the right decisions
so they can escape these
these bad decisions that they were about
to make and
other and people's goals as individuals
should also be not to make the bad
decisions
these these these cycles cannot be
broken by a government coming in and
trying to fix them government tries to
fix poverty
in 1964 and the war on poverty has now
been going
for half a century and by percentage the
same number of people are
poor okay so this is just not working
we're going to need to do something else
and it's going to need to come down to
individual decision making
uh j just to end this um i i want to
thank you for your personal kind charity
um especially
i didn't give you money i can thank you
for your kindness to others
um and i am very appreciative of
everyone who does that i just
uh personally don't believe that that's
going to be uh the solution for everyone
out there
uh but once again i i thank you for
coming and speaking here
and i thank you for advancing the cause
of charity even if you do it in a
way that is politically different from
my own well thank you i appreciate that